отут стоїть прапор Європейського Союзу
ми говоримо Ми хочемо в Європу Покажіть
мені будь ласка одну країну
Європейського Союзу де голова
антимонопольного
комітету де голова рахункової палати є
родичкою родини президента одну я прошу
показати мені одну країну члена
Євросоюзу чи Сполучені Штати Америки чи
Канада Де таке бачили а в Україні Будь
ласка пані піщанська яку не вдалося
проштовхнути
передноворічне засідання тепер
проштовхують в післяноворічне засідання
Ну ви розумієте не треба ображатися
казати Ну як так можна робити де ж
кінець епохи кумавства де розумієте чому
вас не призначають Ну тому що ви не
сусіди президента не друзі не родичі
Ваша сестра не є власницею фірми на яка
оформлена ві родини зеленських Ну не не
пощастило вам розумієте а пані
піщанській пощастило то не треба
заздрити да Та хай собі вже займає всі
посади які є в державі А можна об'єднати
одразу щоб і антимонопольний разом і
Фонд держмайна і рахункову палату бо це
ж буде зручно це буде класно скажіть як
можна до такого докотитись нагадаю всі
посли Великої сімки звернулись до
парламенту сказали
не призначайте нових членів рахункової
палати не призначайте голову рахункової
палати до реформи цього органу І що
робите ви наплювали витерли ноги
призначаємо нам плювати А завтра скажуть
як же так де підтримка де міжнародна
підтримка чого нас не підтримують а чого
нам гроші не дають да тому що ми живемо
за їхній рахунок і вони говорять Ми
хочемо бачити як рахункова палата
контролює що ви не вкрадете це все а
Відповідь Яка українського парламенту
яка відповідь більшості
родичку подруги зеленських на посаду
повний контроль Ну це ж ганьба ну це
ганьба пані піщанська якщо в вас є
гідність і розуміння Ви маєте зараз
взяти самовідвод прямо тут і зараз не
ганьбити Україну Це буде мати наслідки
для України Зупиніться ми в надзвичайно
важкій ситуації нам треба молитися на
підтримку нам треба пояснювати і
показувати свою стовідсоткову прозорість
маємо бути як джерело як джерельна вода
чисті а замість цього знов прилаштовують
родичів близьких людей на ті місця які
мають контролювати щоб не вкрали бо ви
хочете вкрасти А це не можна робити
Зупиніться Поки не пізно